this is probably the volume in which
I'll be talking if this helps you I
sound like someone with voice modulation
now hello look who's here it's go to
John's if you didn't know you're a
goddamn idiot I like to neg the audience
to make them love me more Cody's here
recording an episode of not too deep
with me so make sure you go over to
iTunes and SoundCloud to listen to that
full episode but while I see right that
we would play a really groundbreaking
challenge with each other
you've heard of the 7 second challenge
you choose an activity that you have to
try and accomplish in 7 seconds if you
don't you don't Cody is a vine star
extraordinaire and vine is limited to 6
seconds even though I heard it six and a
half seconds is that true I thought we'd
do the six second challenge today so we
have classically a top hat full of
challenges and a stopwatch so we're
going to go back and forth each
attempting to do a challenge in 6
seconds or less okay and the first 1 to
6 points you get a point if you complete
the challenge is the winner
what do you win leave it in the comments
these challenges I don't know what any
of these are other people have selected
these for I make a farting noise with
your armpit go do it hurry I can't do
this oh that one may take more than six
seconds cuz you gotta like crap it was
right yeah I know like we're gonna shirt
am I wearing
when you got I got like three shirts
about God 6.52 I stopped right on vine
you were vine time I mean I know damn
days too well okay that was unsuccessful
Cody your turn go and do five animal
impressions okay meow ARF
um I think I got like four though you
got four but that's not fine I know I
know so no no points awarded then name
three super villains the Joker um the
guy from Breaking Bad oh the other one
uh Captain Crunch it isn't he in the
Pirates of the Caribbean or something I
think you got to give her a point for
that I mean I get a point for creativity
come on
yes now to my turn here we go we might
have to play like three or you could say
like the person who didn't get it the
other person gets a point so I would so
right now it's 201 see all you would
need to do is alright let's do that so
right now it's two to one okay okay and
BRR there's no air I can't do this time
are you kidding can you burp on command
me that's why she's a superstar three
three two one
I also just so you know all of my
challenges make me so anxious so it's a
really great prep for the podcast okay
great great lick a strange body part I
look my calf is that strange that's
pretty straight yeah it's nice time for
the comeback I have four four points
here we go lady go ahead do an
impression of her favorite cartoon
character yeah um
what's my favorite character uh baby but
that's all folks you yeah you got a time
yeah porky 40 hey it wasn't a great
impression but at least I thought of
someone didn't I
I've worked her so I get my point
seamlessly worked in the stutter yeah I
know directors thanks wait wait what am
I saying
Oh Porky Pig okay okay cool two points
away from grace being the champion say
goodbye in three languages goodbye
arrivederci Irv wha what is this where
did that come from you didn't even say
adios which I feel like it's the easiest
now yeah I went above and beyond you did
when a to see instead of a to be five to
two you can do it lick your elbow I'm
gonna time can you do that no I'm gonna
give that to you because that is
impossible
yeah I know some people have the
flexibility to do that but that is just
I know everyone off camera is trying to
lick their over no you guys are doing
I'm gonna give you a point for that
okay it's 5 to 1 is 5 to 3 5 3 here we
go all right name 5 cereals Captain
Crunch Trix Cheerios um cookie crisp and
fruity pebbles she did it yes captain
crash wins every time we did it this is
fitting that you would be the champion
on on your own channel I mean it it
never happens so I'm having a great day
but I have found something I'm good at
and that's working the stop yeah I'll be
back every episode timing everybody I
see high school track coach in your
future
go Oh Cody thank you so much for being
here and participating in this challenge
where can these lovely people find you
across the internet bored so guys can I
say my youtube because I'm now doing
videos every week now go subscribe to my
youtube channel and you guys can find me
on twitter with the easiest at name
you've ever seen at Cody it's I can't
believe it I made it super simple for
them and make sure you listen to the
full episode the podcast where he'll
explain to me how he got that Twitter
handle
don't want to hear this I'll see you
have a Boston Terrier I do oh my god
okay this is so much you listen to on
the podcast go check it out and go check
out cody on vine and across all the
platforms thanks guys for watching I
don't know it will be like being able to
detach and go to the bathroom for each
other that's kind of a dream I've always
like wished like I don't know that may
sound be able to go to the bathroom for
someone else yeah it's like so you both
don't have to like get out of the car on
a road trip I mean you you know how it
is it's like is so weirdly strange